قال الرئيس الاوكراني
بلاده ستبدا الهجوم المضاد من دون انتظار
وصول الطائرات الغربيه المقاتله واكد انه
لن يسمح لروسيا باستغلال الوقت الذي
تحتاجه قوته للتدريب
بصراحه الدعم الغربي سيساعدنا كثيرا لكننا
نتفهم ايضا انه لا يمكننا ربط الهجوم
المضاد بالخارج ولهذا السبب سنبدا الهجوم
المضاده قبل تسلم طائرات اف 16 او طرازات
اخرى لن نسمح لروسيا بالاستفاده من حقيقه
حاجتنا الى شهرين للتدريب على الطائره لا
لن يحدث هذا سنبدا ونمضي قدما ونحن نستعد
لاستقبال الطائرات المقاتله الغربيه
[موسيقى]
نعم الجديد هو الاعلان الذي اطلقته قوته
فاقنا عن تقدمها في مدينه باخ محمود عن
سيطرتها على المدينه باستثناء كيلومترين
او ثلاثه كيلومترات منها في الجهه الغربيه
وكانت قوه
الاوكراني المؤدي الى المدينه من جهه
الغرب وكان هناك اسناد جوي تقوم به القوات
الروسيه المحموله جوا خلال الايام
والاسابيع الماضيه من اجل تثبيت هذه
السيطره الروسيه التي احكمتها قوته على
الاجزاء الشرقيه والشماليه والجنوبيه من
المدينه تقول قوته فاكرا انه لم يبقى خارج
سيطرتها من هذه المدينه الا كيلو متراني
او ثلاثه كيلومترات في الجزء الغربي تقول
كذلك انها قضت على مجموعه كامله من القوات
الاوكرانيه الليله الماضيه كانت تحاول وضع
حاويه بها
سيطرتها عليها ثم تتقدم غربا باتجاه
الاحياء التي ما تزال تحت سيطرتها القوات
الاوكرانيه طبعا هناك هذه الهجمات على طول
خط القتال اليوم كان هناك هذا الهجوم
الاوكرانيه القصر الاوكرانيه على مقاطعه
على احدى القرى وقال حكمه المقاطعه
وان هناك مبنى مدريا سكريا تضرر بالكامل
او دمر بالكامل فضلا عن تضرر مبنيين اخرين
قبل قليل وسائل الاعلام محليه روسيا تحدثت
عن ارتفاع عددها القتلى المدنيين في هذا
القصف الاوكراني على مقاطعه برياس الى
اربعه اشخاص قالت انهم قضوا جراء القصف
الاوكراني هناك ايضا قصف للقوات
الاوكرانيه وفق السلطات المحليه في دنيا
على عده احياء وعلى مدن من بينها مثلا
مدينه ياسين وكذلك عده احياء في المدينه
من بينها حيوا كيف سكي وحيوا شيفسكي وعده
احياء من مختلفين مدينه دونيت حديثنا عن
تضرري بعضها المباري وكذلك عن جرح بعض
الروايه